[Musique]
il y a comme un petit air de californie
alençon ambiance idate pour ce premier
forum des métiers du numérique drones
east domo titien community manager kane
et 5 designers une vingtaine de
profession et représente community
management mais aussi là c'est je fais
tout la vente en ligne des fiches
produits ces choses là
l'animation autour de notre site claire
et alice sont en licence e-commerce à
l'iut d'alençon pour elle ce salon est
une vraie bonne idée celle à venir au
final ces métiers là et quand on sait
pas trop dans quoi se diriger en a
beaucoup qui vont dire que le web c'est
savoir coder du coup savoir-faire des
sites il y en a plein compassé
compétence là qu'ils pourront pas le
faire mais je pense que ça permet de se
rendre compte qu'il ya plein d'autres
choses d'affaires derrière et dans ce
domaine la croix c'est vous les jeunes
qu'elle est vraiment bousculés les vieux
métiers les métiers de vos parents 50%
des métiers phares des dix prochaines
années sont encore à inventer comme ceux
liés à la réalité virtuelle on choisir
un voyage avec de l'arrêté virtuel on
choisir une maison et de la réouverture
on achètera même une maison qu'il existe
déjà en réalité virtuelle on imagine un
agent immobilier qui veut vendre une
maison d by poids virtualisés la maison
la dépersonnaliser retirer les éléments
de décors qui sont peut être déplaisant
ce forum a été initié par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie
objectif mettre en avant l' orne terre
tout numérique c'est une vraie chance
pour les territoires reculés
c'est justement pouvoir capter les
compétences locales parce que là elles
sont ouvertes sur le monde grâce à
internet et sa digitalisation permet
effectivement de fixer l'emploi dans
tous les territoires et l'orne en
particulier puisqu'on est dans la
silicon valley
au total un millier de jeunes visiteurs
ont peut être découvert leur vocation
dans la silicon valley